what's up guys my name is Colin McNeill
for the score eSports great commentary
can elevate play in any eSport turning
the memorable into the unforgettable
making a good play into one that's
iconic and nowhere is this more evident
than in the fighting game and Smash Bros
communities can come in me I mean I mean
come to me come to me please yeah so
anyways get your bionic arm out and your
haagen-dazs scoops ready because we're
doing the top ten fgc and smash bros
commentator calls oh and before we get
into it guys I need you to hit that
YouTube wombo combo that means hit
subscribe like and do leave a comment
kicking off our list at number 10 is
Ultra David's iconic bionic arm call at
final round 14 it was Marvel vs. Capcom
3 winners semi finals and Combofiend
managed to claw his way back from the
brink of defeat with his final remaining
character Spencer with a magic pixel of
health his Spencer holds on for dear
life
melting Marne zero and Sentinel and
setting the stage for Ultra David to
yell those famous words
Oh double feed sites at 3 and 0 coming
in at number 9 is d1 and his super
fighting robot call during the super
smash bros invitational at e3 2014 hugs
released his mega mans final smash
sending d1 into an absolute frenzy
[Applause]
wanna go save the world
making its way in at number eight on our
list is Bronson Tran at NCR 2017 Tran
had the unique experience of
commentating his own matches at the
NorCal regionals
he took the opportunity and ran Oh Jo
demon he'll eat this demon though
[ __ ] throw and by the way he won the
entire tournament number 7 on our list
is the call behind taquitos infamous
tante combo at Evo 2017 say gem and
James Chen were on the desk for Street
Fighter fives emotionally charged Grand
Finals which featured a matchup between
fgc legend Tokyo and rising star punk in
game 1
Tokyo styled on Punk like no one had
ever seen before we could describe the
round for you the surprise the shock the
awe but honestly no one could have put
it better than say gem
very close he in a but he's so genius
the time he did a talk about a punk a
grand finals of evil I've never seen him
do anything like that at number six
we've got held pockets and metaphysics
at Evo 2017 the King of Fighters
fourteen grand final saw et's diamond
versus xiaohai Z or E and featured a
perfectly timed seismic wave plus one
unforgettable call that's not does not
pop the comeback rap don't wait daddy at
number 5 we have ski Sonic and Yipes
crowning Marvel vs. Capcom returning
monarch justin wong and Chris G went
punch for punch until Justin popped off
reuniting himself with the Marvel vs.
Capcom throne might be the King returned
as the local goddess returned to his
throne I think we're gonna see it
although the king about it you cannot
forget he's planning on being
cleavable he's he's been winners bracket
little time the best beat is the best he
did it
justin wong what skin at the top of the
mountain I can't believe it
you knew this one was coming an
fgc commentary list just would not be
complete without Yipes and his brilliant
stream-of-consciousness
marvel calls at seasons beatings - oh he
so pringles
talking guys
please don't bring unlike some of the
other moments in this top 10 this Marvel
vs. Capcom 2 match could have been lost
to time that is if it wasn't for yips
coming through with some of the funniest
most memorable and quotable commentary
in fgc history and number three we've
got the wombo combo filth mango and
homemade waffles were commentating a
loser semi-final at the SCSA west coast
circuit when silent Specter and tang
decided to juggle zoom what followed was
a call that would go on to become an
internet phenomenon
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
coming in at number two we've got the
now iconic commentary behind the long
factor comeback facing off against types
at evo 2007 justin wong had an
unforgettable comeback with only his
anchor Cyclops still standing it's only
fitting that one of the biggest rallies
in fgc history was complemented by one
of the hypest calls of all time
[Applause]
capping off our list at number one is
one of the most memorable calls in all
of eSports let alone fighting games a
play that's been shown on ESPN
SportsCenter and made mainstream
headlines around the internet at the
guilty gear xrd winners Emmys at evo
2015 whoa she gay made a very costly
mistake in celebrating one round too
early so smart he put in first because
of the super
[Applause]
[Applause]
mushiya thought it was over
and stood up and Ogawa gave him no
remorse not only was the moment hella
embarrassing for she gay commentators
hell pockets and Ryan Hunter famously
scolded him for his premature
celebration thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button